listening is critical in life in
business and certainly in our work on
the stage we can't create something if
we're not paying attention to all the
cues going on around us and for all the
energy and time that we spend practicing
our writing skills and our speaking
skills we do none of that there's no
practice at all for listening and
listening is paramount in business you
have to work at listening you have to
practice that I think the biggest thing
about all of our stuff with
improvisation is it's the idea of being
in practice and not just taking it for
granted and so for listening every
conversation you have whether it's on
the phone or a conference call or a
meeting any of those things those are
opportunities to build a muscle and to
get better at the craft of listening
it's not just the monologue that you put
out it's the ability to create
opportunities for a productive dialogue
and looking for in welcoming the
contributions of others if you want to
become a better listener probably the
single most important thing you can do
or the best thing you can do is adopt
this idea and that is to listen to
understand as opposed to just listening
merely to respond often in our
communication whether it's our personal
or professional communication it's
almost like a game show half way through
what another person saying we've got our
hand on the buzzer ready to complete the
answer we know where they're going we're
done listening to them we want to come
in with our own response usually to
redirect or control the conversation and
often at that point that halfway and
beyond point we lose vital information
we lose the chance to truly understand
what that person saying so at second
city we do a lot of work
honing listening skills and we do a lot
of work with our corporate clients
around listening skills and one of the
exercises that we have used very
successfully is an exercise that we call
last word response and last word
response is really fun and simple we
instruct people to pair up we tell them
to have a conversation about anything at
all business related or not and the only
rule we attach to the conversation is
that a person's first word of their
response has to be the last word of what
their partner said so it might go
something like this hey Jim I just had a
great cup of coffee this morning the
other person would say morning is my
favorite time of day and back and forth
the other person would say day is better
than night
you get the idea and that conversation
goes on and on and we let it go for a
while and then we instruct people we
call a stop to ask them what it took to
be successful in the exercise invariably
we hear things like oh I had to listen
all the way through well I had to really
pay attention I usually I don't pay
attention all the way through when
people are talking and what we talked
about in in second city and we talked
about in improvisation is this idea that
you have to listen all the way through
to get the full intent of what someone
is saying you have to listen to
understand not just respond